there's a lot of good fights at 45 for  me and I train with the kid Bryce  Mitchell multiple times I love Bryce and  he's a tough dude he doesn't cut the  most weight for 45 which gives me  confidence that I could come in and do  some good things at that weight as well  he's tough he's durable he takes guys  down and he makes it look like almost  like effortless what he does he's  undefeated yeah so that gives me  confidence I'd love to watch you guys  grapple oh it's so fun prices are big  there's a couple of good like footage on  us and that's why like I get Confidence  from things like that so and then I see  these guys doing well Bryce is such a  down-to-earth good dude such a good kid  man such a good dude yeah well he gets a  little wild with certain things I find  funny strong American the strongest  which I Vibe when I love